because when people control what you say
inevitably they will control what you
think which brings us to our next story
from Fox Business hello everyone meet
the new boss same as the old boss Trump
truth social developing content
moderation practices to ensure
family-friendly community that actually
sounds like it will be more strict than
Twitter and they go on to say that
they're going to be using the hive
artificial intelligence
TM TG is partnering with Hive a series
of startup providing automated Solutions
through cloud-based artificial
intelligence for understanding images
videos and text content hives technology
provides automated content moderation
across video image text and audio I'ma
tell you what it ain't gonna work
Donald Trump is going to have a more
censorious platform than Twitter than
many other websites now Twitter you know
we'll see but artificial intelligence
moderation can easily easily be bypassed
maybe not easily easily but easily
enough
so what what's the end result does
Donald Trump think does Jason Miller of
getter think people are going to be
leaving Twitter
which is censorious to go to other
platforms that are censorious in other
ways I just don't see it happening I see
people being like okay here's what'll
happen instead of following Trump you'll
sign up for a truth social accountant
follow Trump there and then when you
want to follow the Maga crowd you'll
sign up on getter and so you know where
this leads leads us to it leads us back
to geocities when everyone just has
their own website they just make it you
click it it's 15 bucks bam and they're
actually I think you get a free account
got a little ad box appears on it that's
where we're going it's like you might as
well not even have social media at this
point because everybody's making their
own platform everyone's gonna have crazy
rules yep or maybe I don't know Federal
that'll come along with it yeah but but
but this one I'll throw this one to you
Ian how do you feel about Donald Trump
using an artificial intelligence to be
arguably more censorious than even
Twitter is uh I'm trying to find if the
code is is free or open source it's
Macedon they they spun up Mastodon but
is is Hive because then they can tack on
proprietary stuff onto a free software
Network and you've got a amalgamation of
free code and private code and so the
entire network isn't free
um this makes I think Hive is
proprietary I'm gonna just imagine it is
because I cannot find their code base
and that's extremely disturbing that I
could be doing anything you won't know
what it's doing or what it's commanded
to do but Trump I mean like that's the
funny thing about it right it's the red
white and blue you go to truth.social
it's red white and blue it's a bunch of
fashion and I talk about this like
nationalism is like fascist it's not the
same thing nationalism but when you whip
up nationalist frenzy with the
corporations like truth social that's
fascist I mean red white and blue on a
social network that's fascist why is
that has nothing to do with the United
States it's a private company has
nothing to do with the United States but
what does that have to do with fascism
mean they're trying to invoke National
fervor to get people to sign up for a
social a private company for which
country France Russia or the us
obviously the United States is Donald
Trump
Jason Miller came in here with a red
white and blue suit on dude it's like
they're trying to sell this National oh
he was wearing a blue suit with a red
tie come on man I'm just tired of
turning on Fox News and seeing red white
and blue and MSNBC red white and blue
it's propaganda and she make it green
Getters green or um gab is green like
it's cool it's weird it's new I I really
pretty good country and uh Trump is
trying to invoke a sense of patriotism
red white and blue is a color scheme
it's an America theme color scheme and I
don't think it's fascist for him to do
that I think it's more fashion more
fascistic that it is going to be a
sensor heavy AI automated censorship
it's like I look at as like the first
step on the road to Fascism so I call it
fascism it hasn't it's not obviously not
fascist but it indicates like a thread
that could pull on to find that later
down the road he's obviously going to
censor the hell out of people that's
true so so okay so this is just market
research they know that their base loves
the American flag they love patriotism
this is their whole shtick this is their
thing so they're using the American flag
I don't view that as being fascistic I
will say that it looks like it's coming
down to be a choice between being
censored from the left or being censored
from the right and I do think that it
would be much better if we did have some
form of Federated system where we could
each go and block the people that we
don't like but everybody is allowed to
say exactly what they think I don't know
if we're going to be able to attain true
Free Speech even on the fediverse but we
could at least try it's gonna be better
than this this just looks like a cop-out
to me yeah and I mean I mean I I think
as you know as flawed as Twitter is one
thing I like about it is it does allow
for conversations for on between people
with very very different you know
political views and at least
we even if the rules on censoring seem
arbitrary at times I think it's one of
those things we've just become more used
to them and I think that's a different
psychological response than going into a
new platform with rules that even the
people who created the platform can't
articulate in a consistent fashion you
know like I think we got to be real
about uh online platforms and moderation
stuff and I think Ian probably
understands this there's a reason why
Twitter bans people
the left so so first I'll get political
the left cannot tolerate on in in a
general sense disagreement and
aggressive you know argument discussion
it caused them will Wheaton's a great
example he's like if Alex Jones allowed
to be here saying words I'm gonna quit
and it's like okay well that's too much
bye quit but when they say things like
hey someone's harassing me then
Twitter's like oh I feel like Twitter
and these other companies look at the um
they look at their system and they say
what level of moderation can we
Implement that will maintain the most
amount of left-wing users and minimally
lose right-wing users I think their
whole their whole thing is like how can
we maximize user base because
conservatives are willing to stay on the
platform even through censorship they
know they can censor the right but the
left isn't so they know they have to
send to the right not the left right but
I will I will say there's a reality to
to Twitter and censorship
I don't I don't really check my replies
anymore because I know it's just full of
insane psychobabble garbage not
everybody not everybody sometimes I
apply to people I do but I know that
most of the time it's like yo if I tweet
something and then I look at the
responses of which there's going to be
hundreds sometimes even thousands it is
going to be incoherent out of context
rage narcissism insults
I don't want to bother with it your
reply function to me is is worthless and
I'm not trying to look it's different
for everybody but I've got a million
followers on Twitter or I I don't ask me
why I don't know I tweet random nonsense
but people are following me and I know
that I can tweet something sometimes as
a joke and I'll still get just
thousands of hateful responses I'm gonna
be honest I don't want to use that
platform Jack Dorsey and the people at
Twitter know that so they said okay
we're gonna ban it we gotta start
Banning these people yes which made the
platform worse because they go too far
right that's when it comes to harassment
that's a very vague term especially now
with internet it was a lot easier in the
real world before the internet it was
kind of obvious if someone was harassing
it was a little more obvious now the
Internet it's like if someone comments
on your post over and over and over
again people are like they're harassing
me they're like no they're not they're
just commenting no what would happen on
Twitter is a person would be like the
all these a bunch of people would keep
reporting like a group of like 100
people and be like they're harassing me
they're harassing me and they weren't
according to the terms but because they
would keep getting reported these same
people Twitter will end up Banning those
people yeah to placate the people that
are complaining about a
misrepresentation of the terms I I had
to happen to me one time I was in a a
Twitter debate with a
self-describe black radical feminist
Professor
we got into the debate because at one
point she was this was around you know
she was on a show with Mark Lamont Hill
and they were talking about you know
Texas abortion law and she described
herself as pro-family now having been
familiar with her work I was like that's
not the case she's a person who sort of
celebrates the decline of the nuclear
family right
so at one point
she said the black community does not
need nuclear families to thrive and boy
did that set off a bunch of people now
to be fair a lot of the responses were
talking about her appearance and and I
don't get down like that but when she
finally responded to me she was like you
know black men say that uh black women
should stick up for them and you should
see all the hateful replies and and
people like you you knew what you were
doing when you did that and and you like
it and I was like I was just responding
on substance but I think a lot of times
what the left does is they will take
that type of sort of at those types of
ad hominem attacks and use that as a
reason to not reply to the sort of
substantive issue that's on the table
um and I think that's that's an easy
Dodge the other thing I want to say I
think Ian you bring up a really good
point and I think this is a point that I
see articulated on the new right as I
would call it and that point is to what
extent do American corporations
oh any sense of loyalty to sort of the
body politic the nation in general
um because I think after Decades of
globalism and Free Trade A lot of people
are starting to question whether or not
companies like apple and Amazon and
Google are really serving the interests
of our country because they are quick to
criticize you know Americans in the
middle of the country Trump voters but
our quietest Church mice when it comes
to you know any type of criticism or
perceived criticism of of the CCP so I
think that's the question that's
bubbling up and I think there's a way
for com for companies to feel like no
we're American companies we serve uh
American citizens without it being
fascistic as he was saying well so one
of the components that we've discussed
in the show one of the components of of
Nazism was or fascism was the lucrative
merger of Corporation and state but it
was cultural enforcement it was when the
the entirety of the country was so you
know in line with nationalistic fervor
the company would have to fall in line
or risk being just canceled as it were
right one way to put it we have the
opposite of that right now you know so
so we have literally the opposite of
fascism and maybe that's why the left
was screaming Trump was a fascist
because he did a little bit in favor of
the nation now whereas back then as it
would go is someone would go to the
factory and be like are you producing
steel for the war effort and then if
they weren't it was like whoa shun shun
now it's the opposite now it's
um who's that who's that who's that
invisible wrestler guy
oh John Cena John Cena Yeah Yeah so
wrestler guy yeah yeah you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah he he go he
makes a video praising China or I'm
sorry apologizing to China yeah and that
is the ex and that's the acceptable
thing LeBron James Mark Cuban they're
actually pandering for China look I
think there's a fine line between yeah I
think I think there's a decent amount of
room in between fascism yeah and
communism we can very much be in the
Middle where we're like our companies
should not be selling us out to foreign
adversaries we also don't expect you to
fall in line through cultural
enforcement to mass produce for the
nation or whatever right so so so
um I'd have a slightly different take
right even if it's not the sort of the
mass production for the nation
I remember back when you know citizens
united that decision came down from
scotus and you know Mitt Romney famously
said that corporations are people too
and he got hammered by democrats but now
the political ties have turned to the
point where Democrats know that big
business is in their back pocket so when
Delta criticizes the state of Georgia
for its you know voter laws or when you
know they they different companies you
know basically all the Fortune 500
companies sign up or sign on in support
of the quality act or when they say
we're not going to go to this particular
State because of its abortion laws I
think big business has inserted itself
um into some of these political
conversations both in terms of trying to
move the needle in the in in the left
Direction and as we've seen it for
vaccine mandates as the enforcement arm
of the federal government so the
companies say okay we know the feds
can't mandate that everyone get a shot
but we think that we can force our
workers to do it so the federal just say
hey we want the companies to do X and
then we'll take on that responsibility
to get you know our our employees as a
term as a condition of employment to do
what it is that the federal government
wanted them to do that's crazy I I'm
worried about what you're talking about
about this is the good conversation
about corporations and what they owe the
country that you know they're based in
the United States but for all I know
Amazon Google and apple are about to
pick up and move to China their
headquarters and just say bye bye Money
Talks politics is passe what what do
they oh it's all about like does the CEO
want to stay American at this point what
right I mean maybe they owe the
shareholders like they I don't think
it's part of the corporate charter that
they have to stay in the United States
um Monsanto moved its headquarters got
bought by bear basically merged with
bear and now move their headquarters to
I think England I'm not sure where
they're at now but they've been Google's
headquartered in Ireland I think right
smart fiscally smart but obviously these
are not American companies all right
they were started here off of our offer
off of our taxes our roads our Blood
Sweat and Tears and then they up and
relocate so you know what really drives
me crazy is when the left is like Amazon
paid no taxes or whatever and I'm like I
feel like it's kind of a distraction the
real issue is the Panama papers yeah
remember that yeah the journalists who
existed that's a big deal actually the
bank accounts in Panama that they're
that are popping up all over that
apparently belong to Putin's buddy and
like all these really and that's the
kind of the story that came up in like
no one would touch it right but so I
mean everybody was talking about it and
the journalists died for like a week
then there was like another release that
I got quashed really quickly but what
these companies are doing is I don't I
don't care necessarily about the taxes I
care about the fact that they've sold us
out period yeah that I'm pretty sure
Google's an island I could be wrong but
they're they're setting up in other
countries
They Don't Care About Us they don't care
about the United States you know Google
wanted to do that was a dragonfly or
whatever that Chinese search engine they
were arguing with it they all want to
just be dominant Global Powers right so
it looks like uh alphabet which owns
Google is in uh Mountain View California
right now it's called an American
multinational company what the hell does
that mean that they work that they exist
everywhere but they're headquartered in
America right but are you looking up
their American headquarters are you
looking at their action alphabet
headquarters alphabet Inc you can't look
up the headquarters you got to look up
their like place of incorporation or
whatever because because you can have a
a Venezuelan headquarters you can have
you know what I mean right and and I
think where the companies are located is
one thing right A lot of people in
particularly both probably both right
and left would love to see more Goods
whether it's PPE whether it's microchips
produced in the United States you know
bring them to Baltimore or you know
Chicago wherever
but I think the other piece of it is
that these corporations insert
themselves into our political
conversations
oftentimes against the will of the
voters like the the voters in Georgia
elected A legislature and and a a
governor to address their issues where
are all these companies come in and
saying no we stand against you know what
the voters in Georgia want to do and to
punish them we're going to move the MLB
All-Star Game
from Georgia to Colorado and I think the
extent to which these companies as I
said insert themselves into our
political process that is one of the
things that I find to be very very very
disturbing so
um so regarding true just a real quick
point of clarification I believe
everything I've looked up says Google is
headquartered and based in Mountain View
California there's often talk of their
Dublin Data Center and that's probably
what I was confused interesting so I I
assume they would be based in America
America for now but I don't think they
have to like stay in them in the United
States I don't know how that works or
they could probably you know bail uh if
Sergey and and Larry want to say bye-bye
yeah it's terrifying yeah when it comes
to truth social now we're talking like
it's a social network that like has some
American he's trying to show us like
it's got American values you know it's
red white and blue right but when I look
at it and I see a private proprietary
Network that is blatantly going to start
censoring I just don't get the American
values in it like you can slather it
with an American flag but unless for me
unless you're going to make that code
base free then it's not really a free
network well yeah the other thing too is
that one of the core tenets of American
value is the freedom of speech it's
literally in our first amendment so I
think that it is perhaps a little bit
disingenuous to plaster the American
flag I do think it's just a marketing
tactic because they know their base
whatever so it's sorry no good but it's
so I looked it up it's called the double
Irish Arrangement it's a tax strategy
used by multinational corporations to
lower their corporate tax liabilities
that's crazy so um
yeah we don't pay American taxes or they
it reduces their taxes I think the Irish
are upset about it as well because it
pulls money from their country it also
allows Google to operate and
you know probably avoid tax in the
United States I have to look up the the
nitty-gritty details but even outside of
that you know I don't I don't think
Amazon or Google or any of these
companies have our best interests at
heart no no thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday at 8
pm now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time